[موسيقى]
أولاً في يوم إجازتي ، نذهب إلى الأسفل
لاكتشاف عجائب أستراليا ،
مرحبًا ، إنه لأمر رائع أن أكون في أستراليا ،
مرحبًا بميلاني ، مرحبًا بكم في جناح التدريب هذا ،
حسنًا ، سمعت أن هذا النفق هو
أحد أكثر الأجنحة شعبية ، حيث
يرمز هذا النفق إلى التعددية الثقافية الأسترالية
ما تراه هنا في الخلف هو
عدد من الفنانين الأصليين الذين
اجتمعوا مع فنانين أستراليين
وبنوا هذا النفق بشكل أساسي لنا
للترويج لأستراليا كمجتمع
مفتوح ودولة منفتحة ، وهذا ما يجعل
أستراليا فريدة حقًا فلماذا هي
مهمة بالنسبة  سيتم
تمثيل أستراليا في معرض إكسبو في دبي ، لذا فإن
أستراليا تستفيد من
الثقافة الاجتماعية وكذلك
الأعمال والتجارة
والاستثمار. كل شيء يتعلق بالمال ، الأمر
كله يتعلق بتحقيق نتائج
لأستراليا
[الموسيقى]
ما هي تكلفة إنشاء شيء
مثل  هذا الأمر آه انظر إنه
أه متنوع تمامًا لذلك لدينا
تكلفة تشغيلية وبيئة تشغيلية
وأيضًا الأصول  نحن الذين
نديرها ونحن نتطلع بشكل أساسي إلى حوالي 30
مليون
دولار لتشغيل جناحنا ، ولكن كان علينا
ما يقرب من 200 مليون دولار
من عقود الشركات المقيدة
، والموازين تجعل
[الموسيقى]
من المنطقي أن نرى كل هذه  الأجنحة
أعني أنه من الصعب زيارة جميع البلدان البالغ عددها 192
ما لم تزورها كثيرًا هنا
السويد ، على سبيل المثال لديك ليتوانيا
البرازيل سلوفينيا كلها تحت الموضوعات الفرعية
للتنقل بالفرص بالإضافة إلى
الاستدامة.
هنا يدين
بغابة صغيرة مذهلة في
وسط الصحراء ،
مرحبًا بكم في جناح سنغافورة ، هل
هو الأكثر شعبية ، أود أن أقول إن الجناح 192 ،
هذا من بين أكثر الأجنحة
شهرة ، حسنًا بالتأكيد هذا هو
الجناح الأكثر خضرة في معرض إكسبو
2017 بأكمله  . يوجد بها أكثر من 80000 نبتة
في موقع تبلغ مساحته 1500 متر مربع
80000 80000 نبتة ، لذا فهي ليست مجرد
نباتات خضراء ولكن أيضًا خضراء بمعنى
الاستدامة ، نعم نحن  يبلغ عدد الألواح الشمسية 517
الموجودة على السطح والتي توفر لنا
طاقة كهربائية كافية لتشغيل الجناح بأكمله
على مدار الأشهر الستة المقبلة.
من ملعبين لكرة القدم
حتى الآن بعد ثلاثة أشهر من المعرض ، استقبله
2.5 مليون زيارة ، ولأنني محظوظ
سيكون اليوم السعودي في المعرض ،
والآن بعد أن استعدت
للعلم ، حصلت على قبعتي ،
نعم
وسوف تدلني على
جناح
المملكة العربية السعودية لا تفعل المملكة العربية السعودية شيئًا صغيرًا وقد
حطمت ثلاثة كتب غينيس للأرقام القياسية العالمية
أكبر
تدفق ضوئي تفاعلي أطول ميزة مائية تفاعلية
وهذه هي أكبر شاشة مرآة LED المفضلة لدي في
جناح الإمارات العربية المتحدة  شيدت على
شكل أجنحة الصقور وهي
مغطاة بألواح شمسية ويمكن أن تفتح
في أقل من ثلاث دقائق ولكن ما
يربط هذا المعرض معًا
هو قبة الوصل وهي
rgest قبة 360 درجة
في العالم وتدب فيها الحياة مع
غروب الشمس
جاكوس سي إن إن دبي